food safety concerns have recently
gained attention in society as part of
the food industry we recognize that
certain National Brands remain dedicated
to producing food responsibly working as
a junior Factory employee I've observed
how basic dust prevention evolved into a
more advanced liquid sterilization
process this phase is particularly
interesting using traditional techniques
to create a visually impressive scene
machines handle the next steps
transporting products via conveyor belts
for Quality screening syrup is added and
mixed before baking in a long oven and
cooling a person monitors the process as
machines fill and seal the packages our
corn harvested once a year in
northeastern China is carefully selected
for popcorn production this product
Blends tradition and modern
craftsmanship promoting healthier
families and nostalgic flavors